avec exercices pour de nouvelles recrues
une simulation des horreurs qui les
attend dans l'ukraine
dans quelques jours cet homme sera à
kiev avec le des bataillons d'étrangers
luttant contre les forces russes
rinspeed
à l'excès juge très mauvais qu'une armée
envoyé ce pays tue ses citoyens
il est lui-même simples citoyens
biélorusses touché par le sort de ses
frères slave exilé en belgique alexei
laisse un emploi et deux adolescents
derrière lui pour guy pourtant
pas d' excuses set offrant qu'il faut
aller
alexei intègre un bataillon spécial t
exilés comme lui tous opposés au régime
pro russe d'alexandre loukachenko
le bataillon inspiré de castes ou
kalinowski héros national de la lutte
anti russe au 19e siècle
le dieu qui les recrutent ces sept
hommes des volontaires pas belle coup
tarn a vu des dizaines passer tous prêts
à combattre au côté les ukrainiens l'est
de protection vêtements nécessaire de
survie tout est donné par les exilés
bélarus qui serait plus de 400000 en
pologne
dès l'invasion de la crimée par l'armée
russe en 2014 des bélarusses s'était
joint aux soldats ukrainien pavel
coûtait y était il y a été blessé cette
fois il reste à varsovie une
contribution logistique à l'effort de
guerre
il n'y voit pas qu'un combat pour
l'ukraine mais un combat pour tous le
bélarus en 2020 le pays a été secoué par
la violente répression de manifestations
contre le président lukashenko un
autocrate au pouvoir depuis près de 28
ans
le régime au bélarus ne peut survivre
sans vladimir poutine croit l'un des
représentants de l'opposition en exil
les cubains je sais qu il espère une
victoire des ukrainiens parce qu'elle
aiderait aussi aux efforts des
bélarusses pour l'indépendance et la
démocratie de leur nation
c'est aussi comme ça que de nombreux
volontaires voit cette guerre
c'est une autre chance de changer les
choses lancé l'ex est prête à donner sa
vie pour l'ukraine et le bélarus
ici il y avait du beau parent
radio-canada varsovie